[拍手]
はじめましていまご荘櫂咲きましたサイトを上げろと言います
今日はよろしくお願いします
私はパイオニアです
何のパイようになかったです
ゲームのノウハウをゲーム以外の分野で応用する
っていう考えを提唱しそれを実践しているんですね
ビジネスとしてもずいぶん成立するようになってきました
なぜ私はじゃあパイオニアとしてそういうことができたのかというと誰かが作った考え
方とかで剤とか環境とか上に自分なりのアイディアとかを打ち込んでそこで何かをする
というのではなくて
そのメディアそのものを成立する仕組み考え方を考えて
それを提唱しそれを実践しそれをビジネスにしてい
ですので歳最初の一人でもあり今もうそれを実践しているパイようにあるということが
言えると思います
30年近くゲームを作ってきているんですねもう50半ばなんですけれども
まあその流れゲームを作ってきた中でです
ゲームにあるひとつ大きな特徴があるがいやもっといっぱい特徴なんですけども
っていうことに気がついてきていってね
それというのは
ゲーム以外にも応用きくなというふうに思っていたんですがまずゲームについて考えて
みましょう
ゲームは小さなお子さんも対象ですから間に俺を読まなくても複雑なゲームが誰でも
遊べるようになっていますよね
誰でもプレイもちろん海外でもその辺ページ
なっているわけです
それからまぁ最初は簡単なルールの理解から始まって
だんだん難しいことを覚えていって最終的にはゲームをクリアできるところまでそれを
持っていきたい
もっと知りたいという気持ちになってクリアするところまで遊んでもらうように作って
います
それから3つ目まあこれがゲーム慣れだと思うんですけれども
小時間集中してハマってしまうんですね気がついたら一時間たったとか
下手すると朝になったか見ての経験を持っている方もいらっしゃるかと思う
これをですねゲーム以外の目で見てみれば
マニュアルを読まなくてもプレイできるというのは例えばどんな複雑な機械
どんなに行こう
怒ったものであっても直感的にそれが操作できるというようなことを我々は何十年も前
からすでに実現しているわけです
2段階的に学習してクリアするということは一般製品でいれば
機能を使い切るということなんですね
もっと知りたいもっと使い込みたいという気持ちになってもらって最終的にはその機能
を刺す隅々まで使い切っているということになるわけです
長時間集中でハマってしまうってことは製品で言えば
もしくはサービスといえば
庄司鑑賞期間お客様とそのサービスを提供している側に置いて
時間を長い時間をかけた中で人を幸せにするというノウハウがそこにあるということな
んですね
であれば歩いこのゲームのノウハウはゲームだけに届けてを止めておかずに
いろんなメディアに応用できるのではないかということを考えて
それをまとめたものが
ゲームニクスという
んですねまあ一言で言えば人を夢中にさせるノウハウというものを理論体系化したもの
なんです
まぁちょっとそれどういうもの気になる彼と思うんですけれども具体的にちょっと話し
てみます
ゲームニュースに多く5つのカテゴリーがあります
一つ目は食感的で快適なインターフェイスを示現するためのノウハウ
二つ目はマニュアルを見なくてもいかに押し付けがましくなくユーザーにその使い方を
知っていただくかと言う
3つ目がまあ思わず夢中になってしまう
4つ目は段階的な学習効果をどうやって組み上げていけばいいのかというのがある
5つ目がバーチャルとリアルをどうリンクさせるとさらに利便性が高まったり面白さが
広がったり
いうことものなんですねこの3つの大きな桜があるんですがさらにそれぞれのノウハウ
に細かいポイントがあります
まぁ今回は時間がありませんので home
中になってしまうまずハマってしまうと言う
ところにどんなポイントがあるのかというと
大きくまず5つポイントがあるんですね
でこのポイントをそれぞれ実現するために注意しなければいけないという点がこれだけ
あるんです
もちろんも小さくてを得ないと思います
でこのノウハウにを実現するためには具体的にどんなことをすればいいのかということ
がこの下に細かく
記述されているんですねですのでゲームに釣れるを理解すればどなたでも思わず夢中に
なって弾き込んで
その世界にどっぷりとはまってしまうようなノウハウが身につくんです
じゃあ
具体的に年者はその直感的で操作性とルール押し波内に理解するなんていうのはどう
いうもある持ってもまああるひとつのゲームでちょっと説明してみたいと思うんですね
このゲームの基本アクションは3つですまず敵を避けながら横に移動してゴールを
目指す
二つ目
ジャンプ
なんとなくなんのゲームがちかも知らせ
で3つ目まあブロックをたたいたりしてアイテムを入手する後スカジャンとして適用に
おける
んですねー
この3つもこのゲームはこの3つの基本のアクションなんですけどもこれを小さなお子
さまでもマニュアルを見ないですっとこのルールを理解してもらうためにどういう工夫
がされているのか
まず1番目敵を受けながら4個以上してゴール目をするんですか
田店って全店始まるわけです
でこの辺にキャラクターもいるわけですねなんでここにいるのか
それは
気がボールですよということを操作を誘っているんです
ほとんどの人が右に入力してくれますキャラクターこの市文化ですねそうすると息を
生かしていくとですね向こうから記録の理由も見ていってるんですね
もちろん敵か味方かもわかりませんなので多分フランティックとターンと語って
倒れちゃうですね1人ロスしたわけですあこれは敵を避けながら
ヒザ右のほうに向かって進んでいかなきゃいけないゲームなんだなって一番メア
約2秒でユーザに伝わりました
1人目ががられてしまうと正さんにキャラクターベルンで2人目で走るスタートするん
ですね
そうすると
最初に教育いって言ってきてぶつかっちゃいました今度はをそろそろ言われる
出てこないかな出てこないかなってどれくらいかなとやってるとこの辺に何か光って
いるクエスチョンが出てくるんですねー
気になりますね光ってですプレスちゃうな
でちょっと上にあるわけですって何をしようかなと思ったより行っているとやっぱり
その人に入ってボタンを押してるっぽいジャンプするんですね
やっぱり上にあるからじゃああるを叩こうということでジャンプして叩くわけですね
ですのでそのここでジャンプをするんだということを知ると同時に
さっきの敵もジャンプして良ければよかったんだということを書くかた心に誓うわけ
ですよ
それでまあブロックを叩くとちゃレーン d 音をするんですね
なんかいい感じだぞ思ふ
もうちょっとをそろそろ行くとですねことまた光っているブロックなんですね
question さっきいい感じ運動したわけですから今回も叩くわけです
そうすると目って音がしてさっきの化け物そっくりな記録ができるんですねー
でこれは誰が見ても敵が出てきちゃったと思うわけです
やばい敵が出てきたどうしようかなぁと思っていると勝手に動いてですねフォトっと
落ちて向こうの土管には跳ね返って自分に近寄ってくるんですね
さてさっき敵はジャンプしておけると心に近くつ
固く誓ってますよねどうしたら避けるかあっというまです金子に来るのはやっぱりその
キャラの記録は手前に来た段階でジャンプして避けようとしまう
そうするとご覧の通り
天井が低いですからすぐ落とされちゃう
ですので避けようと思えば避け様と思うほどキャラクターに当たるように作ってあるん
です
そうするとキャラクターに当たるとにネット薄暗くねー
さっきまでこれなかったブルー分を壊せるようになるわけですから
あこれはフェイスチョンを叩いてアイテムとかを出して
チェーンを進めていくゲームなんだなってことがこれで理解できるんですね
ここまで30秒くらいです
これでもう言葉が呼べないの小さなお子さまでもこのゲームの基本アクションが理解
できるように作られているんですね
けっこうすごいと思いません
であれば先ほど言ったようなゲームのノウハウを
ゲーム以外の分野で応用すればはもっともっとまあ
生活が豊かになったり楽しくなってるんじゃないかというところが私の発想の原点に
なったわけです
まあそういう目で見るとですねたとえば駅のホームと彼はのちからっていくともうこう
いう
デジタルサイネージって言うんですけども柱にモニターが埋め込まれていろんな情報が
提供されているの皆さん見にすることが多いと思います
もうこうなったらタッチしたら反応があるとかっていうのはもうそこまで来ています
そうしたらゲームというのはインタラクティブな遊びですからタッチして反応がある
ことでお客様をどうやっても中にする
どうやって注目させるどうやって自分たちに伝えたいことを伝えるかということです
から
まさしくゲームのノウハウが応用が効くわけです
ってちょっとこうじゃあ鉄砲買いに行こうとも敵の券売機の方に聞くと
まぁ自分はそこに来たいなぁと思ってるわけですが要するにそこに行くまでいくら
かかるかわかんないから結果品してるわけですよねなのに券売機見ると品額しか書いて
ないわけです
いくらのキープを買ったりしかわからないに金額が出てるわけですから
こんな風にゲーム作ったら嘘ゲーとかダメゲーとか良い手ですね
お客様にあっという間に拒否されてしまいますですのでこういうデジタルも引きに関し
てもゲームの脳応用すればお客様に何を迷う異なる自分の目的を達成するような情報を
提供するノウハウがあるということです
評価書も今や紙からこういうデジタルのものに変わろうとしています
ということになればこういったデジタル機器に教科書を入れたときにですね
ゲームの脳波を入れればゲームに夢中にされるように勉強に夢中になるわけですから
これは世界変わりますよね
実際私がある教育委員会に頼まれて作った
インティくれる積分のですね教科書中学生がキャーキャー言いながら夢中になってやっ
てましたね
あれ普通に教科書に帰ったら俺の人生に関係ないなこれはと思ってほとんどそれし
ちゃうと思うんですけどもまぁそういう効果があるわけです
これは私がある大手自動車メーカーと一緒に作っているリハビリ音です
半身が麻痺してしまった感じがリハビリをするためのロボットなんですね
リハビリっていうのは同じことの繰り返しですから
辛くて大変なんですねでもゲームの rpg ゲームなんかはレベルを選んての文字今
ところ繰り返しが楽しくて楽しくてしょうがないわけですねそのノウハウをこの
ロボットに入れたわけですちょっと自分でもちょっと膝の動きが違うからあったかと
思ったらアラームのように
ぶーているブザーをがあって
何度あの体重が移動したらちゃんとクリア音というか
出てくるんでわかりやすいので
よくなりたいの一心で全然不安もなく先生を支持て
距離を稼げるイメージで枚刃で言ったので
もうめっちゃ集中しますねえええ
距離を稼ぐとかねめっちゃ集中するんじゃねほとんどゲームの世界ですかね
これでこのリハビリの患者さんも楽しくリハビリ魚は mp にやっているわけです
ですのでこの言語ノウハウを導入したものっていうのはよくゴールにこれから使われて
いてどんどん世界に広がっていくと思います
そういうもののメディアをつくったのが私なんですね
じゃあ私はゲームを作りたくてこの業界に入ってきたのかというとそうではありません
実は最初はアニメだったんですね置かれてるんですね
そしてあれば次にある人誘いがあって雑誌編集者になったんですね
今度は名アウトとか
v 字を書く仕事ですね
そしたらまたある誘いがあって今度はこの走るディレクタ
広告を作る
仕事に就いたんですね
そしてまたある人も出会いがあってゲーム業界に入ってきました
大きな出会いがあったんですがその方はこの方ですこれは私の結婚真珠に司会をして
いる人なんですけれども
誰だかわかりますかね
残念ながら数年前病気で亡くなられたんですが全任天堂の社長をやっていた岩田さん
です
彼に二十歳過ぎの頃に出逢いがあって彼に誘われて
ゲーム業界に入ってきてずっと一緒にゲームを作ってきました
まあそういう意味ではアニメーターも雑誌編集者もを回したらもだいたい人との出会い
があって
その人たちににさそわれるようにしてそこのところに入っていてチャレンジをして
そこでいろんな成果を上げてきたですので人との出会いが私を今この場所に導いてくれ
てるんだと思っています
そのことで言えることですねまぁ今日会場見ても若い人いっぱいいると思うんですが
まあこれから世の中に出て行ったり仕事をしたりしようとするときに
自分はこんな本ができるんだろうなぁとかこんなことをやりたいと思っているとか
どうせこんなことは難しいだろうなとか色々想定していると思うんですよ
考えていると思うんですね
でもこの年になって確実に言えることは
もしくはこの会場にそれが年齢がたのがいらっしゃれば同意していただけると思うん
ですが
人生想定外の事しか起きないんです
ですので皆さんあれこれ考えている想定なんてのは全く意味がないんですね
じゃあどうすればいいのかなぜ私がバイオ la に慣れたのかそれはあることに熱中
する
そういう才能があったからだと思っ
それはアニメーションの世界だろうが雑誌の編集の世界だろうがその他
夜の水商売とこの人もあるんですけれども
なんでもいいんですいろんな業界に入ってそしていろんなことにチャレンジする中で
自分が夢中になれる所々
自分は熱中できるポイントはどこなんだろうということを常に考えながらその仕事をし
てきました
その中で
自分のコアとなるもん支援となるものなん
自分がブレない面白がられるポイントは何だろうということを見つけてきたんですね
それをもとに
いろんなことを考えていく独自の視線や視点っていうものを養ってきたと思います
皆さんもなければもう
こうだろうがああドローなって想定することはやめてですね
ぜひいろんなことにチャレンジしてほしいんですで自分のパワーとなる核を見つけて
ほしいんですよね
若い時は生駅でも誠実であればいいんです
いろんなことに発言もしいろんなことに挑戦をし
それで壁にぶち当たったり楽しんだりすることを経験しながら自分のパワーをどんどん
どんどん作っていくそして柔軟性のある自分を
描いてって欲しいですね
そうすればどんなことがあってもどんな想定外のことが起きても芯がブレないんです
から
どんなことになって自分の考えをもとに対応できる人になれるはずなんです
今日皆さん
これからですね
そういったことの見方を変えて
常に自分を変えるように
今日から代わっていただきたいと思います
だいたい今私大学教授やってるんですよ
それを充電もてるんですよ第楽曲集2分争点をしていないですよ
で今もまた違うプロジェクト後全く新しい視点のプロジェクトも始めています
これももうすでに形になりつつあって大きなプロジェクト勝手にして com
それはそれでまた世界に問いかけられるような
俺になっていくと思います
初めからそれを狙っていたわけでもないですしそこを目指していたわけでもないです
自分のコアをつくって生役でもいいから誠実であって自分のコーン
作って言ってある程度自分のパワーができた10%安性もできた
これなら自分を売れることなくいろんなことに対応できるぞと思ったらば今度は人との
出会いを大切にしてほしいです
そしてその人との出逢いをもとにいろんな仕事をしたりプロジェクトをしてそこで得た
もの利益というものを
その一緒に関わってきてくれた人たちすべてに還元するようにしてください
そうすればまたその一緒にプロジェクトした人たちの中から
笹今度ご一緒にこんなことはありませんかってこういうをかける人が出てくるはずです
そしたらもう盛りそこに取り組んでいけばいいんですよ
こうして
いけば
絶対皆さんも何か一つのパイ御簗れると私は信じています
未知の領域に足を踏み込んでください常識にとらわれないでください
自分もフォアをつくってください今日今この時点から自分を変えていくように
努力していただければ
私がここに来たいうも少しはあるかと思います
今日私はここに来ることを
セッティングしてくれた皆様
それから強行に聞いて私お話を聞いてくれた皆様に
とても感謝しています
今日はどうもありがとうございます
[拍手]